what's with the jeans so why I didn't
realize you're so multi-talented I mean
brilliant comedian DJ and now painter
it's pretty amazed the thing is you
might not know this or believe this
looking at that painting
I'd never painted before oh wow you know
I just picked up a brush yeah mm-hmm so
terrible whenever you draw me remember
when you used to be used to draw each
other like on airplanes and stuff yeah
and you know you drive me the same way
with a big hook nose and then my mouth
open and my tongue speaking out but
that's inaccurate you want to draw you
right now
I'd like that yeah are you gonna you're
gonna draw I'm gonna drop it we get to
keep talking go ahead but do you want to
see my profile as you draw my release I
can see it oh yeah okay make sure it
looks accurate okay so here we go we're
gonna get coverage now of you drawing
okay
is there anything we're boring for a
listener to hear you draw something well
we can keep talking that's what my whole
point was okay okay okay I am okay we'll
put this on line okay two seconds I was
able to bang out a drawing of you yeah
that's the drawing you always do of me
that's the one you always that's not who
I am
wait hold on let me see like it look
like this there you go I just nailed it
I got your teeth down perfectly I got it
okay I did a great job can I draw you
now sure give it to me
no the listeners have to see this so
make sure we pose this I know right
here's you do you want to see can you
see what that is yeah that's really cool
though it's accurate right yes what do
you think it's rude as I got your
beard I got the color and your beard you
just drew a butthole
yeah but I got your mouth there's your
mouth
in hair around it you hate me you're
only I love you I love you